a new poll shows that only 12 percent of
people believe Joe Biden should lead the
Democratic party as I've said before I'm
not particularly shocked by Joe Biden's
low low numbers
um approval rating number of people in
the Democratic party who don't want him
to run again it's not really hugely
surprising because Joe bides is not
exactly an exciting high energy guy even
if he has accomplished a lot of really
important things the question for me is
are a lot of the people who say I'd
rather someone else
still going to vote for Biden if that's
who's on the ticket in 2024 or will they
stay home or vote for a republican my
belief and I'll ask you what you think
let me know in the comments I believe
most Democrats who say I'd rather the
nominee be someone other than Biden if
it's Biden versus Trump or Biden versus
DeSantis are still ultimately going to
vote for Joe Biden let me know what you
think